torrents of water still flood through
the streets of towns and villages in
swat valley in the north of the country
communities cut in half by the waters of
this absolutely massive disaster
thousands upon thousands remain cut off
here
a huge tourist destination dozens of
hotels are amongst the buildings simply
washed away
just crossing the river is precarious
and terribly dangerous
many have
further south people try to salvage what
they can from their destroyed homes
a cupboard has floated downstream
they've managed to save this but most of
everything else has simply disappeared
where they find dry land they sit in
makeshift tents hoping that aid will
reach them soon
after the flood though doctors are
warning that waterborne disease could
quickly take hold of a population now
homeless and exposed
medical teams are doing their best but
it's a huge task
pakistan's prime minister met some of
the survivors and is promising to
rebuild their communities but he
reflects the views of this country that
the world's climate crisis is to blame
for this catastrophe
the people of pakistan are apparently
suffering in the form of their lives
their livelihoods
for a catastrophe that is not of their
making pakistan produces less than one
percent of the carbon
footprint but is one of the
worst affected areas from climate change
some rebuilding work has begun on
highways smashed by the flood waters
so the international aid is being sent
to the country but distribution is
extremely difficult when the
infrastructure has been destroyed
food medicine and temporary housing are
all needed across the country
in punjab some displacement camps are up
and running but this disaster like most
natural disasters doesn't just end
they often get worse
stuart ramsey sky news pakistan